my dad used to go to this bar called
stennies and across the street from
stenes is a place it's now called Lage
it's still a gay bar but it used to be
where dmer would go Troll And if he
didn't have luck there he would go
across the street to steny's and so my
dad was at steny's after his best
friend's wedding and this guy came up to
him and started hitting on him very
aggressive and was like grabbing his ass
and like trying to my dad was like a big
[__] Jack dude and he came up to him
and he was like um I'm going to give you
3 seconds to get away from me my dad
said this and my dad was like one and
then dmer was like two damn three he
[__] knocked him out laid him out
cold and this was this was in 1991 so
this was right before he was about to
get caught literally his his friends
that were with him at the bar that night
called him like a few weeks later and
they're like that guy is on TV and it
was Jeffrey [__]
dmer the Honeydew with Ryan sickler